chronologiquement
je vais vous dire ce que ce dont on est
sûr et après j'évoquerai peut-être des
hypothèses il y en a malheureusement
beaucoup mercredi donc dernier on était
le 25 janvier
cette jeune fille de 18 ans qui est
lycéenne elle passait un bac pro et en
terminale
rend visite à sa grand-mère
et vers minuit elle son père au
téléphone et elle quitte assez
précipitamment le domicile de sa
grand-mère
elle avait été un rendez-vous en tout
cas c'est ce qu'elle stipule sur les
réseaux sociaux
alors elle donne pas le nom mais on
comprend avec qui elle avait rendez-vous
donc c'est un certain mahfood Mahfoud
qui est un garçon de 39 ans qu'elle
connaît bien parce qu'il est le mari de
sa cousine d'accord comme je disais tout
à l'heure donc son cousin par alliance
voilà d'accord il se trouve qu'il y a ma
food et ça et la cousine sont en train
de se séparer sont en train de divorcer
ils ont deux enfants et Siam est
accessoirement au-delà de ses études la
baby-sitter du couple on sait que ce
jour-là ils ont dîné en famille Mahfoud
a gardé ses deux enfants dans la journée
parce que sa femme travaillait son enfin
celle avec laquelle il divorce
elle est venue à leur difficile ils ont
dit ensemble et ensuite elle est
repartie avec les enfants ce qui fait
qu'il était tout seul
et à partir de minuit et quelques
minutes plus de son plus d'image au
téléphone ne répond plus et elle
disparaît
les écrans radars
le papa s'inquiète fait un certain
nombre de recherches et finalement
dépose va signaler la disparition de sa
fille au commissariat de police d'Alès
compte tenu du village dans lequel ils
habitent c'est du ressort de la
gendarmerie et finalement c'est bon ça
c'est une tambouille judiciaire qui n'a
pas un grand intérêt bref ce sont les
gendarmes de la SR de Nîmes et de la
brigade des recherches d'Alès qui vont
se charger des recherches
et assez rapidement le nom de enfin le
prénom de Mahfoud apparaît à peu près
partout tous les proches l'évoque alors
on évoquait son casier judiciaire tout à
l'heure effectivement il a été condamné
à 13 reprises il y a eu 8 affaires qui
sont des infractions de la circulation
il y en a 8 pour des infractions de
circulation et les synchrones c'est des
vols violences violent gravés
volamar mais la dernière affaire c'était
un saucissonnage mais en fait elle
remonte à 2011 mais elle n'avait pas
encore été jugée où il avait séquestré
un couple dans un dans un domicile
c'est des propriétaires d'un bureau de
tabac et ils les avaient obligés il est
obligé le mari à revenir sous la menace
de l'arme sachant que sa femme était
séquestrée pour faire la caisse etc donc
c'est un voyou clairement alors il est
inconnu pour des affaires de mœurs
et il est également jusqu'à preuve du
contraire en tout cas il a jamais eu de
problème pour des affaires de stup
d'accord voilà donc en gros alors il est
entendu une première fois par les
gendarmes parce que son nom apparaît
tellement dans l'entourage de CM que les
gendarmes voudraient approfondir un
petit peu tout ça et
il se trouve que il se justifie il donne
des il explique que ce jour-là il était
avec un ami que enfin bref il donne un
alibi les gendarmes avaient pas
suffisamment de billes comme on dit pour
l'accrocher donc il le laisse ressortir
il était pas sous le régime de la garde
à vue
les investigations évoluent avancent et
à un moment donné parce qu'il a il y a
des il y a des indicateurs enfin il y a
des indices des tontons comme on dit
dans le dans le jargon qu'il replace
dans le dans la boucle et qui disent ça
peut être que lui d'accord et ils
évoquent une sombre histoire de de
trafic de stupe alors au début on
pensait qu'au début c'était qu'une
histoire d'argent c'était une histoire
d'argent c'est oui même la justice il a
cru ça alors que on a priori c'est pas
tout enfin ça sent le pas et de ça
l'histoire d'argent ça serait des gros
voyous ni moi qui se serait fait
carotter donc voler
karaté une grosse une grosse quantité un
montant de 50000 euros
par la nourrice et il se trouve que si
elle ressemblait à la nourrice et donc
dans les trucs c'est pas du tout ça on
sait pas trop ça peut tout est possible
on n'a pas de certitude absolue et ma
foudre avait échafaudé aurait échafaudé
un scénario en organisant un faux
kidnapping de Siam en la faisant passer
pour
touristes qui lui ressemblait pour
récupérer les 50 000 euros incroyable
alors qu'est-ce qui se serait passé
il la connaissait donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé alors
je vais vous dire déjà ce qui commence à
se passer ce qu'il a dit jusqu'au moment
où il passe aux aveux au moment où il
est mis en examen donc il est placé en
garde à vue les gendarmes vont user
quasiment toute la garde à vue
c'est-à-dire 48 heures 24 + 24
et en toute fin d'audition en toute fin
de garde à vue enfin dans la nuit en
tout cas il va lâcher juste qu'il a eu
une relation sentimentale amoureuse avec
sienne et il s'arrête là
il en donne pas plus et à ce moment-là
il demande à au gendarmes la possibilité
de voir son avocat un bon moment un long
moment je crois que ça durera à peu près
une heure d'accord
et quand il revient il reconnaît le
crime
il dit en gros que il avait une relation
sentimentale amoureuse avec Siam avec
Siam pardon
c'était une relation qui devait rester
cachée
pour des raisons évidentes ils font
partie de la même famille enfin bon le
divorce est pas prononcé etc et que
Sihem c'était un moment haché de lui et
voulait révéler enfin voulait rendre
public cette relation et qui se serait
disputé à cause de ça et que dans la
dispute un moment il l'aurait été tout
fait et après il serait débarrassé du
corps pour aller le
déposer là dans ce petit chemin une
dizaine de kilomètres d'Alès ça c'est sa
version ça c'est sa version
il y a quand même pas mal de pas mal de
problèmes ça correspond pas trop au
personnage c'est pas un type qui a des
principes avec son casier judiciaire je
vais pas faire le le café du commerce
mais bon c'est un type qui a pas trop de
principe sur le sur le fond donc qui est
une relation sentimentale avec sa nièce
ou un verre avec la nièce de son ex de
sa femme qui est en train de devenir son
ex-femme je pense que ça le saloit pas
le ranger plus que ça le déranger plus
que ça
je note quand même dans une affaire
précédente que dans son enquête de
personnalité on s'était aperçu que son
père avait 30 ans de plus que sa mère
d'accord et peut-être que ce modèle en
ce schéma familial m'avait 18 ans si
elle m'avait 18 ans il en avait 39
exactement donc
si vous voulez c'est très compliqué
parce que cette affaire ne fait que
commencer
vous rendez compte que on a retrouvé le
corps cette nuit donc ça va très vite en
fait le temps médiatique va une vitesse
hallucinante et pour l'instant il a pas
comme il a été il a avoué en toute fin
de garde à vue que les gendarmes avaient
plus de temps pour l'entendre en fait il
a entendu sommairement et ensuite ils
l'ont déféré donc ils l'ont présenté un
juge instruction qui l'a mis en examen
même les chefs d'accusation enfin les
chefs d'incubation on dit plus
inculpation mais de mise en examen
pardon risque d'être évolutif parce que
comme la justice avait cru à ce scénario
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure de stupe
de carottage etc
ils avaient ouvert en ce sens
a priori attendre d'autopsie évidemment
mais a priori c'est un meurtre alors il
diction est morte lorsqu'il l'a étouffé
[Musique]
il parle d'une dispute sur fond donc de
relation sentimentale et puis elle s'est
mise en colère j'ai voulu la faire taire
et il a dit j'ai plaqué ma main comme ça
donc voilà j'ai plaqué ma main donc là
on serait plutôt sur l'étouffement les
premières constatations on verra
l'autopsie mais est-ce que ce serait
plutôt un étranglement est-ce qu'elle
serait morte de mort violente voilà il
faut préciser quand même que la famille
et l'avocat de la famille ni totalement
la thèse de la relation sentimentale et
non d'accord jamais connaissance de
cette relation sentimentale ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'elle est éventuellement
eu lieu mais pour le moment ni la
famille ni l'avocat de la famille ne
reconnaissent la moindre relation
amoureuse entre
la jeune femme qui sont meurtriers
présumés mais ça veut pas dire qu'il a
pas existé qu'est-ce que j'ai dit c'est
ils avaient pas forcément en tout cas
lui il n'avait pas forcément envie que
ça se sache alors si vous nous rejoignez
les 21h06 on parle de de cette affaire
cette chambre par cette jeune femme de
18 ans retrouvée morte dans d'atroces
circonstances l'homme qui est passé aux
aveux s'appelle mafoud c'est un homme de
39 ans placé en garde à vue depuis mardi
puis on détachant des tensions
provisoire depuis ses aveux
il est bien connu des services de police
comme on l'a dit il a déjà été condamné
en 2015 avec deux autres complices pour
des faits de vol en bande organisée et
de braquage à ma armée dans la région
d'Alès en 2012 il devait comparer hier
c'est sale la vraiment ça c'est une info
importante parce qu'il devait comparer
hier devant la Cour d'Assise du Gard
pour vol Ammar mais un home jacking
et donc il devait il devait comparer
trop là quelques jours après le meurtre
oui il devait il devait comparer
toujours été placé en garde à vue
je crois que le process ouvrait mercredi
ou mardi devant la Cour d'assis de Nîmes
la question que tout le monde se pose
libre
tous les petits spectateurs qui nous
regardent ils doivent se dire quand même
il a eu 13 condamnations il a quand même
lassé quand même des faits importants
volants d'organiser braquage à armé
pour ça qu'est-ce qu'ils font dehors
c'est la question que je pense alors ça
je peux vous répondre
le parquet le parquet de l'annonce comme
ça il a purgé toutes les peines pour
lesquelles il a été condamné alors c'est
vrai que c'est court il y a une peine où
il a pris 12 ans et a priori il est
resté 5 ans avec le jeu de remise de
peine mais la duralec c'est de l'ex mais
bon c'est la loi c'est comme ça
je dis pas que c'est bien je dis pas que
c'est pas bien je dis que c'est la loi
voilà donc il est resté cinq ans en
prison en tout il a fait plus de 12 ans
je crois que c'est 20 ans le il
encourait une peine de 20 ans de
réclusion mais là il était quand même en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire il
était placé sous contrôle judiciaire
c'est là où il peut y avoir un débat
éventuel plus ou que je crois que si
hein
ce qui pose problème en fait voilà c'est
effectivement que il est condamné en
2015 à 12 ans alors il a fait 3 ans de
préventive avec les remises de peine il
est sorti et c'est vrai que c'est
toujours le débat des remises de peine
alors la loi a changé mais il y a des
remises de peine automatique qui font
que quelqu'un qui a été effectivement
condamné très souvent dans cinq fois
pour atteinte au bien et puis il y a des
condamnations quand même vous l'avez dit
hein Cyril volant dans l'organiser
braquage à ma armée un personnage
reconnu par les experts psychiatriques
comme dangereux narcissique cette
personne est en liberté survient ce
drame épouvantable donc inéluctablement
se repose la question de qu'est-ce qui
faisait en liberté à ce moment-là et ça
c'est une vraie question on peut pas
l'esquiver
on peut y répondre
la loi a été appliquée là dans la ferme
on vous parlez il a été condamné en 2015
à 12 ans il avait déjà fait trois ans il
est sorti en 2017 donc il a fait 5 ans
sur 12 ans et après le reste a été
aménagé j'y peux rien c'est comme ça
on va écouter juste Dylan qui s'est
exprimé devant le palais de justice de
Nîmes son père a été braqué et sécrété
par l'homme qui a avoué avoir tué
regardez
dans l'histoire de cm c'est lui qui a
séquestré braqué attaché mon père ça
fait 11 ans que notre procédure a une
semaine de du procès de mon père des
individus comme ça sont encore dehors
c'est c'est pas normal ça fait une
semaine qu'on se barricade chez nous
qu'on a peur de se fout il a détruit la
famille de tout le monde il a détruit
notre famille il a détruit la famille de
CM ses amis c'est inadmissible c'est
inadmissible j'ai pas d'homo c'était une
proche de la famille de sihem donc tout
était pré
une personne comme ça n'a rien à faire
en liberté on peut pas réinsérer des
gens comme ça alors ça vous entendez ça
je suis sûr que vous avez tous retenu
une seule phrase ça fait 11 ans qu'on
attend le procès 11 ans et ici si même
et voilà je vais me faire engueuler ça
on a on avait dit à un moment il
faudrait que parfois ce soit un peu plus
rapide et tout le monde nous est tombé
dessus hein tous les donneurs de leçons
qui nous sont tombés dessus si ça avait
été plus rapide il y aurait peut-être
pas eu ce drame je vous le dis donc là
là je vous dis ça c'est ça c'est
incroyable ça moi ça me révolte je suis
désolé 11 ans qu'ils attendent le procès
son père a été saucissonné c'est ils ont
il a foutu une famille en l'air il était
en train de se promener et même
peut-être d'avoir une relation amoureuse
avec quelqu'un non mais les mecs mais on
marche sur la tête il s'est excusez-moi
franchement c'est c'est on devient fou
on les les gens deviennent fous
excusez-moi c'est c'est inadmissible je
sais que vous n'aviez pour rien Michel
marine mais malheureusement c'est ça
quand on a parlé nous ici de c'était
pour les exemples de la malheureusement
on a les preuves on a les aveux on avait
tout et on nous a dit qu'on avait fait
des dérapages
justice expéditive 11 ans 11 ans combien
11 ans 11 ans il faut attendre bah faut
les laisser dehors les mecs laisser les
dehors ils prennent 12 ans faites leur
faire 5 ans là bah voilà bah les
remettez l'emprison il y a des gens ils
ont jamais affaire à la justice de toute
leur vie jamais il s'est des citoyens il
se tiennent droit et il y en a d'autres
ils vont à une fois devant la justice
deux fois voire trois allez trois fois
allez trois fois combien il a été de
voir la justice vous voulez rincer un
mec qui a été 13 fois devant la justice
alors allez-y allez-y rincez-le
donnez-lui
je dirais un sérieux en règle générale
quand les gens me tombent dessus
donnez-lui des pâtes faites-le jouer à
la pétanque
tous les bières de son allez-y mais en
attendant il y a une jeune fille
en attendant on vit des drames en France
on vit des drames tous les jours et et
il est bien pensant tous ceux qui nous
ont dit qui qui ont parlé de ça là quand
ils ont vu la 11 ans qu'il attend de le
procès cette femme c'est normal 11 ans
c'est normal
horrible horrible on s'est tous dit vous
allez voir qu'on est en France ça va
durer une semaine ou à pleurnicher et
qu'on va passer à autre chose exactement
mais voilà il y a quelque chose qui est
en train de se tramer au niveau des lois
et des machins non là on est sur la
retraite et tout ça c'est autre chose
mais pardon de parler un peu comme du
café de commerce mais il se passe rien
rien avance rien n'avance à chaque fois
se déroule elle est incarcérée sa sœur
tu l'as le coupable il est là je vais
apporter de l'eau à votre moulin ah dans
l'expertise psychiatrique du du procès
où il devait comparaître j'ai relevé
quand même des choses incroyables une
déficience intellectuelle légère des
troubles cognitifs une capacité
d'élaboration d'analyse et
d'autocritique très déficitaire
une personne narcissique pour du tout
non orgueilleuse têtu impulsive immature
ne parvenant pas à intégrer l'autre dans
la relation et j'ai fini sa dangereuse
était n'est pas psychiatrique mais
crimonologie
automatique et puis si vous avez 12 ans
c'est 50 c'est automatique
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui il risque jusqu'à combien de
prison bah là ça va dépendre de la
qualification quand on va lui
possibilités minimum 30 ans d'accord ce
qu'il encourt en l'état c'est minimum 30
ans
si on arrive à établir qu'il y a une
éventuelle
ce jeune homme qui a 38 ans est-ce qu'il
peut en faire 20 alors sur les longues
peines comme ça
la justice leur donne généralement une
peine de sûreté d'accord donc c'est
généralement les deux tiers de la paix
20 ans et donc là avant qu'il risque de
sortir enfin temps parce qu'il est et
moins de 60 ans il reprend une vie
normale alors qu'il a tué une personne